mouse gum resumes and welcome back to
Walking Dead episode 3 season 2 it came
out today
I literally just came back from Japan
like 30 minutes ago
I should have been sleeping 6 hours ago
I'm so tired
we've been traveling for like 15 hours I
just wanna sleep but it's only 6 o'clock
here when in UK and I have to stay up
and the game is out and I'm like hell
yeah I'm gonna play it it's a part of me
if I'm really sleepy
but I just can't wait playing this so
without further ado let's do this [ __ ]
press it's good to be back I had a great
time in Japan I'm gonna yeah walking
good I'll be another video who do you
think did this think about it you're
carver what do you do what's the most
important thing in this world see I was
right about that question and everyone
was like why can't and some family
people like Matthew aren't coming back
well yeah they are at Sammy's sorry I
tried to make a joke Rebecca our baby
deserves to be raised in a place of safe
go to hell you
we're going home as a family
I actually last episode was so [ __ ]
good I actually replayed everything to
make sure because I really wanted to say
the bold guy but you can't save him no
matter what you do he dies which is a
bit of a shame the the african-american
guy can die if you [ __ ] up
but in my playthrough he didn't die and
we're back with Clive behind staring at
a tree are you gonna eat that you about
done over there the hell Academy yeah
one second
don't talk you climb like that it's
scary out here wasn't claimed I know
they made you it's still nice that you
came
we're safer if we stick together it's
gonna be dark soon yeah I know but just
pull you came I thought they were gonna
tell my dad to go with me
thanks that's gross
everything come out alright girls what
that fukk Troy get him tied up will do
now we're on our way probably 30 minutes
out make sure everyone's prepped
emotions might be running high
Carver out but the truck is running
ahead and wasting fuel to keep that
[ __ ] heater going I'll make you walk
back Oh
froze my ass off just like you told me
to it ain't polite to listen to other
folks conversations
has anyone ever taught you that where's
your manners sorry I'm sorry
vans okay huh well chalk it up as a
lesson learned all right get the girls
in back with the rest of them we got a
bit of a drive ahead of us so he's the
voice from that guy from Kill Bill if
anyone saw that movie Ian such a badass
voice are you guys okay the hell did he
do to you hey did he hurt you
he made me Pope right how could he so
we're back and we have to go back to
their camp or whatever I don't think
that's a nice place I don't think we're
gonna stay there for very long I hope
there's gonna be a throwdown
but at the same time I think episode
four would be the beginning of episode
five you know I'm saying maybe there's
surprises and make an episode six
that'd be cool except I wouldn't be that
surprised
because I called it we'll see
Jesus he took a punch Carlos
god EDIS biting my Kim all right we got
to do something come on anyone got
anything sharp anything we need to get
these bindings off hey Clem help me find
something to get these off anything
sharp ticket cut these and what good is
that gonna do what the hell is wrong
with you people
we gotta get out of here like what what
do you mean like what something sharp
anything that can help the [ __ ] I
don't know anything we're in a [ __ ]
precarious position here we gotta do
something about that town Kenny they
took everything we offset our level head
he's right you don't know Bill like we
do bill this whole time it's carver
carver carver now he's [ __ ] bill yeah
oh I see what it is y'all were just
getting a ride home aren't you that's
what's going on here say that again I'd
stay out of this boy miss Rayna boy I
know right you're a man you don't
understand he's different
it's worse the [ __ ] car about he
wants to punish us what do you mean
worse yes psychopath now you have no
idea what you're dealing with oh he gave
me a pretty good goddamn idea back at
the lodge I can I don't intend to sit
around here and let that happen to the
rest of
I'm trying to help I'm sure Walter
really appreciated your help
like you helped Alvin oh yeah yeah
you're blaming him for the actions of a
madman I'm pointing out that regardless
of intent there are consequences to rash
actions something that he seems to be
miss reading as capitulation I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're saying but I
know it's [ __ ] we have to do
something Kenny you can't reason with it
oh [ __ ]
jackpot what sigh sit down you're going
to get us all killed
y'all don't know what you're talking
about we get cooped up in some kennel
like a bunch of [ __ ] dogs it's over
you don't know yeah well I've been in
this situation before you ever been a
prisoner Kenny please calm down yeah I
think everyone is just tired and cranky
she's right we should all take it down
of it
alright now we're talkin we'll be on the
other side of that door with ten people
that's kind oh okay
every doesn't be fine at this point
maybe Luke is the only hope we have ya
gonna do something he'd have done it by
now
who knows what he's dealing with
anything can happen out there I'll tell
you what happened he abandoned us you
don't know that I know he ain't here he
may not be around but he wouldn't just
leave us behind
that guy's a flake I could tell the
second I said I saw Kenny please calm
down I really don't miss them on this
side of Kenny huh when after that crazy
[ __ ] killed us all death Hey look clam
we're closed
okay let's do this they have guns what
exactly do you expect to do I'm gonna
punch the first son of a [ __ ] I see
then I'm gonna take his gun and use it
to shoot the next son of a [ __ ] a seat
just sit down Graceland Rock
this ain't your call hey just if
something happens just help out okay
don't you know get yourself hurt or
nothing but any help would be good
sure hey cliff look at me you trust me
right
no Kenny please just just listen to them
I'm scared kiss a little girl come on
that's okay that's okay all right Kenny
are you okay
is he okay I think so Oh what hit me
it's probably for the best what the
fakty brakes ain't workin quick [ __ ] oh
all right
open Adam he did it brain Evan good
Kenny good job Ken the [ __ ] how'd you
get you restraints off please superpower
I would just pretend that they were
still on or some [ __ ] I don't know I
guess I understand some of you are
confused and why we bring these people
back think I've got an idea might not
come on once but time will heal these
wounds
be patient with them until it dies you
take solace in knowing they're here to
help us make our home a better place all
these feelings you have anger betrayal
eight they're all valid no one needs to
forget what they did but we do have to
find it in our hearts to forgive them
look how much food they have I hope you
ain't saying what I think you're saying
it many of you already know large herd
of lurkers gathers come on we need you
for something couldn't wait until more
not you're all exhausted just come to
[ __ ] on come to [ __ ] ow he looks after
all right
you're with us Roja he'll be back he'll
be back when I don't know but he will
come back yeah Jesus Thanks make sure
y'all stay off the fence
bill can see if you're messing with it
just to survive is our obligation to
make this community
bacon
thanks Barney you really a bright light
bright enough to shine in all this
darkness so that you all best get some
rest
is there ain't gonna be much for you
tomorrow you're gonna be working hard
that's for you yeah it would be [ __ ]
bill keeps me out in the cold but at
least I'll be comfortable hey guys
Ritchie who the freakin hell nah sorry
I'm so sorry what did they do to you
yeah this could have been worse trust me
lucky to be alive it's my fault no it's
really not I would tell you if there was
this happened well after you guys left I
guess I should spread she helped us but
when we ran away waiting hey God Joey
why didn't he go with you guys
when you left I think maybe he was
supposed to but then he fell and
everybody kept running oh geez oh we had
both his arms then oh damn they got me
working outside Mercker snuck up on me
while I was hammering something
luckily they took the arm off quick Oh
save my life
ah that's awful I'm so sorry
look it was my choice to help you guys
hey Reggie oh hey Troy don't go [ __ ]
up now Bill's real close to letting you
out of here
you make sure things stay nice and quiet
out here tonight and I'll be sure to let
bill know just how helpful you were yeah
you can count on me thanks Troy
don't mention it pretty sure he's hello
let me introduce you
Oh mom we got caught but it's nice to
see I like it li ke hello and that's
Kenny hey yeah hello who are you
this freaks you out Hey that reeks me
out too sometimes my name is Clementine
it's very nice to meet you Clementine
well yeah I'd leave she lost and left
our blows bills already got him looking
at some folks oh ok good what about Pete
Oh occurred can you guys save it for the
morning some of us gotta be up early
what a jerk who's that I don't know I
don't recognize the voice no problem
sorry about that what if it's me that's
Mike he's kind of a dick when he's tired
but like I said he saved my life so I
put up with that [ __ ] Belle put him to
work ups at the wall with me
I'm so sorry stop with all the sorry it
was my choice besides he said once you
were all caught he let me rejoin the
group so I'm glad you're here I'm just
joking I know I mean he did say that but
I'm not happy about it so why is she off
by herself hmm who her over there oh
yeah right okay so she's [ __ ] weird
the founder sneaking around outside the
camp covered in guts and just like the
grossest [ __ ] it's probably best not to
stare I know how it must look but it's
really not that bad here Reggie no I'm
serious
where else are you going to find food
like we have we've got the canned stuff
and now with the greenhouse is coming
along we've got fresh food the
building's getting more and more secure
all the time mostly through forced labor
but that's only temporary sure even got
the solar panels working when was the
last time you had electricity huh oh we
just came from a lodge with a wind
turbine it's not a competition not as
bad as you think was building something
great here guys a real community bill is
making it happen
look I've made mistakes and he's
forgiven me that doesn't make up for
what he's done Reggie I know that but
I'm starting to see what this place
offers I didn't before and with the
accident
it's just that much more important now
Carver killed my friend Walter
okay I don't know what happened but
maybe he had his rescaled Alvin to Jesus
yeah and that's a positive now I'm
really close to getting like back into
the group
what's that happens I can do a lot more
to help you guys be more comfortable
comfortable what do you think this is
just don't want you to mess things up
for me I've worked really hard to get to
this point will you please just try not
to cause any trouble at least until they
release me then once I'm out I could
help you more okay maybe even like get
on thanks ray sure thank you it means a
lot she don't speak for all of them yeah
but if she doesn't want to cause trouble
she doesn't have to we can at least talk
about it more in the morning just have a
quiet night and chat again tomorrow I
can't believe what I'm hearing
look the fact is Bill had every reason
to kill me when I helped you guys but he
didn't obviously I don't know what
happened while you were all gone but
he's given me a second chance and I know
he'd do the same for you but the father
I don't want a second chance after what
he did to Alvin I want him dead
this I need to sit down yeah come on
Sarah can you go see if there's
something for her to drink okay you had
this water over by the benches ah that
didn't go as planned
should have actually made a place good
John
[ __ ] that guy I don't think we can trust
him
I mean clearly he's already drank too
much of the kool-aid yeah I think he's
this scared scared yeah everybody's
scared ain't an excuse to sound like a
nutcase you gotta take a look around we
gotta know if there's anything we can
exploit to get out of here we're in a
tight spot
can I have to be that way out oh sure
I'll have a look around
that Troy [ __ ] gone for now this is
our chance
don't worry about Richie I'll go help
her an interference on them okay so we
need to look at Ione for safes that
can't make us go out later snuck up on
you huh yep I was distracted just wasn't
thinking there's all kinds of noise I
get to hear them in the back I saw its
shadow it moved in front of work how
they all how do the walkers always sneak
up on them like how are they so slow
I mean so sneaky
that faith that all right we're not
finding anything here so they got this
place really locked in tight huh maybe
climb can sneak out though hey Clem come
on don't be like that she ain't doing
nothing wrong Reggie just relax
how can I relax when she's walking
around touching everything I've keep
touching [ __ ] he likes it let's be
honest love those tiny sequences reclaim
what is that anyway oh they don't even
talk anymore
this is stare-off looks kind of crappy
so how'd you bury her the name like
Reggie kidney what I'm just asking yeah
I'm curious too actually looks rickety
I don't agree Neville Eris hey clown
Nick just thinking about Luke just
there's no way he's gone dead he left
its chair how about it cuz me I known
him for damn near 20 years now and I
can't buy it
of course I can't say the thought never
crossed my mind I asked evidence I don't
know in that world change I don't know
her enough to say never everybody's
still out there yeah you watch
why wouldn't he help us before we got
here I don't know I just know he's out
there still he's smart smarter than me
that's for sure
hmm guess I'll try and get some sleep
you should too
just thinking about being smart make me
sleep sure okay night that was [ __ ]
quick Jesus
like having a conversation but I wish I
could do that
edible gardening 60% off guess it's
better than the ground it's not really
everyone's saying so much bad things
about this place I understand that
they're treat them bad and make them
work or whatever but needs to have food
over there hand up awkward sorry
anybody pee on you okay fish statue yes
that must be a key out of here why of
course why didn't I think of that look
at it lemme look at it good
no Clemmy Clemmy didn't like fish fish
statues hello sad she doesn't appreciate
find an ark you lost that was fun
well out with it do you see any way out
of here
got nothing the fences seem pretty
strong yep yeah they do all right a
whole house full of building supplies I
guess it ought to be dad oh geez
all right go the [ __ ] to sleep I'm
shooting the first one of y'all I see
wandering around before sunup everybody
get to pair some of these folks ain't
too keen on leavin it's up to us to
figure out a way out of here you up for
it it's your decision I'll try I'll try
you'll do just fine
I don't know we can't forget something
lame we'll need it seems like Zambia
ouch witch or something I don't [ __ ]
know
get up Bill's gonna have a word
what is he gonna do have a speech for us
again [ __ ] Melanie's speeches there's
been increased Walker activity along the
fence so be mindful when outside the
walls the herds moved a little closer as
of this morning but that still doesn't
necessarily mean we'll be hit
no we're monitoring the situation now
there are some folks might be sore about
what happened and how things went well
that's all in the past now oh really
some of you are new to our community
some of you are members who went astray
but know that you can find redemption
here forgiveness by proving your worth
through what will undoubtedly be hard
work frickin very net to cam back in
keep following the path and we'll
welcome you back with open arms how'd
you sleep I'll let Reggie be an example
elevation is available but hanging
wasn't gonna hurt pay attention Kenneth
will be taking all these registries
outside go girls yeah sounds good so I
know Michael will continue on I'll show
you value Carlos yes your child seems to
be in need of correction oh sorry
hey Sara apologize to mr. Carver um
sorry sir no no that ain't gonna cut it
I can't have this kind of behavior on
day one of your reform you discipline
her now Carlos ah opposed that one good
smack across the mouth should do it
you'll make her think twice before
opening it up again go on we'll wait
no my I'm not sure with my hand that I
glad why you got two hands Carlos come
on not some namby-pamby thing all right
a good hard smack otherwise Troy here
will do it for you I don't think you
want that he can be overzealous is that
the words if it means I'll slap the [ __ ]
out of him then yeah go on Carlos
it's my fault no one's [ __ ] talking
to you unless you want one of what she's
about to get I pipe down Missy Oh who's
gonna get this ivy that's [ __ ] up man
I'm sorry dad I'm sorry honey
it's only going to sting for a second
you'd be really gonna do it do it do it
oh that's [ __ ] up
I'm sorry so stop you're not calling
that girl anymore let her sit there and
think about what she's done Troy get
Carlos to his post everyone else you'd
have their assignments it's time to get
to work he's not damn you really knocked
the [ __ ] out of her die
everyone get to work you're working in
the armory follow me all right Bryce I'm
sorry but I gotta in this episode he oh
so I hope you enjoyed watching if you
want to leave a like that would really
help me out a lot especially when this
is a new series going on in absolutely
more stuff it shows excitement and that
you're here and you're watching and
great stuff it's great to be back
that's for you thank you for watching
I'll see you tomorrow with a new episode
[Music]